and we're back with all the action we
see that jan nakamiyachi has won that
game against karen alexianco we were
discussing it before we left for a break
uh and dave i also see that magnus has
decided to join us uh one more time so
he didn't
rage quit as i was uh thinking that he
had so welcome back magnus
uh dave let's just go through the last
couple of moves that happened
in this game uh he decided to go for the
plan that we were least expecting he
actually went for queen c
queen eight seven i think he just
calculated calculated it
all the way through uh let's do a
play-by-play magnus david take it away
yup queen takes h7 came um and as
predicted black
well black pretty much had his capture
this night um a few tactics here we did
get to this position btake c4 and here
jan decided to play e4 i was having a
chat with you magnus in the break and
you were surprised
yeah i was very i was very surprised to
see this but
i suppose he um he just calculated
everything here and it looked very very
convincing
um and it seems that what will win
a second pawn without having to trade
queens
and then it's uh it's plain sailing
um so yeah right now it's equal but he
will win
he will win um uh the pawn on c4 and
and one one more in either f7 or a6 so
uh unless i i'm missing some or i'm
missing something and
alexandra missed something crucial there
uh it seems that
this was actually very very clean uh
and yeah
a typical typical conversion
like you need you you only need to win
the game
once and you only need um
you only need to win you don't
necessarily need the fastest way or
the best way to win you just need a win
that you've calculated so
i think he did this very nicely
yeah and uh just to explain why black
resigned i mean okay
not many uh well not much choice here
but at the very least white can
just grab another pawn as magnus says
yeah and if queen d6 instead of
king um
[Music]
king d7 then queen s7 king d8 for
instance then you would just grab an f7
uh i guess you could fight a little bit
here with black you go g5
and then you go bishop e7 uh
but okay probably
two pawns and a better bishop not not
realistic no
you can even start advancing here with
your king at some point as white
yeah very very positive yeah alexander
decided he'd seen enough um after quincy
five track
and yeah jan he's looking good in the
tournament
and the tournament standings right now
yeah and uh as it turned out
um he made a good opening choice here
today
it's not unheard of for yon to
to play one c4 uh he's played a lot of
the english
before i think especially aiming to play
against
the reversed sicilian
but he clearly called caught alexenko
off
off guard and alexenko either played a
bad line or
didn't know the line well enough doesn't
really matter
anyway the result was that he was i
think lost after the opening
it's it's uh as much as that and
then um probably wouldn't take a strong
player
a stronger player as napoleon to convert
but it doesn't hurt either